- Ship is when you think a girl and a boy
are perfect together, and you
put their two names together.
I ship.
(bouncy, playful acoustic music)
- A lot of the boys are very shy,
and a lot of the girls are very talkative.
- Most of the boys have crushes on girls.
- Like let's say this is
a girl and this is a boy.
- My best friend Michael,
I promised to get him a wingman,
and he was my wingman.
It was like, tssss,
wingman to wingman.
- Well there's one boy that
we know has a crush on,
and she has a crush on him.
Everyone knows it.
It's just they don't know it.
- Well the one who picks on everybody,
he said it to me that
he had a crush on me.
- Some boys are meaner to
girls when they like them,
so they think they'll hang
around with them more.
That's not the way to get
them to like you back.
You have to show respect of kindness.
- Me and my other couple friends,
we went up to Ariel and were like,
"Talk to Ethan."
So she said, "Hi,"
and they started talking,
and then we came up
'cause she walked away,
and she said, he said,
"No, and turned me down."
So we're like, "What?"
- I think third grade girls are smarter.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Most boys now in my class respect girls.
Some boys just aren't like that.
They think it's ewwww, that kissing,
but it's really part of life.
You know?
(bouncy acoustic music)
(creaking)